what's up everybody its Warren thanks
for stopping by the channel today we
have a lot of hype right now about Black
Widow the trailer is expected to be here
within a week recent reports say that
the trailer is expected to be here
either December 2nd or December 3rd so
if that ends up being true then we can
expect a trailer a week from today but
to hold you off until then we have
reports of a leaked trailer description
by somebody who has seen the actual
trailer now this is kind of likely
because the trailer is supposed to be
here within a week which means some
people have probably seen it already and
this leak comes from the Instagram
account MCU underscore India and then it
was posted on credit but MCU India is
the original poster so I'm going to
break down and go over at this leak but
if you would like to see the black widow
trailer unspoiled I suggest clicking
away now also be sure to subscribe to
stay up to date on the MCU and for your
chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 more
about to giveaway at the end so here are
some of the details shared about the
first black widow trailer that should be
coming soon by MCU underscore India the
trailers first dialogue will be the one
from Avengers endgame which was present
in the San Diego comic-con trailer as
well while washing her face Natasha says
I used to have nothing then I got this
job this family I was better because of
it I've made mistakes I can't go back
now of course this is the dialogue from
Avengers in game where Natasha is
talking to Steve Rogers now it would
make sense that the trailer would open
up with this dialogue because she died
in Avengers in game this is of course a
black widow prequel in case anybody
didn't know that it's taking place after
the events of Civil War and before the
events of Avengers infinity war so again
it makes sense that they would open with
that dialogue then the dialogue
continues as the footage shows some
flashback scenes from previous MCU
movies that show some of the Avengers
Nick Fury and others this also makes
sense for the trailer now this makes
sense too because Marvel actually did
this width Avengers in game they showed
clips of previous movies in the MCU
before showing new footage of the movie
so we'll get some old dialogue and then
we'll get some flashbacks as well but
then we see Natasha on a mission where
she met a Russian agent aka
Yelena Bulova and calls her sister where
both of them point
at one another and then they fight each
other the fight ends as they both pass
out now this lines up with everything
that we know so far we know that Jelena
Bulova is going to be in the movie we
know that she calls her sister and if
I'm not mistaken some people have
claimed to have seen this footage of
yelena and natasha fighting so all i
need up so far but then the next shot
reveals the family reunion as this
leaked closet of natasha romanoff with
her sister figure elena Bulova father
figure alexa shasta qov aka red guardian
in a long beard wearing a red suit and a
mother figure Melina vasta cough and the
leak says that this could be red
Guardians wife but in this scene there
are jokes regarding someone's weight and
being so fat that the old suit might not
fit them now this joke is most likely
made at red Guardians expense who of
course is going to be played by David
Arbor he's most likely donning the red
guardian suit for the first time in a
very long time and he's probably packed
on a few pounds since then then again it
could just be the sisters poking fun at
one another but unfortunately we'll have
to wait another week to find out but it
is nice to know that in a movie that
could be very very serious there is
going to be some humor in it but the
leak goes on to say that also there's
somebody else's voiceover present in the
footage but the source is confused and
isn't 100% sure of whether or not it's
Nick Fury's voice or somebody else's the
source says most of the things have been
blurred out apart from the characters
faces and their voices due to some
security reasons which makes sense they
don't want some things about the trailer
to get out which apparently they already
did so sorry Marvel but that's it for
the trailer except for the fact that the
source mentions that the trailer is
exactly two minutes long now keep in
mind that this is a teaser trailer
they're not going to really go full into
depth on what we can expect from the
movie it seems like part of it is going
to be old footage and old dialogue mixed
with new scenes that we can see in the
movie but it seems very believable to me
and like I said the trailer is expected
within the next couple of weeks so it
makes sense that people have seen it and
if somebody has seen a trailer it's sure
to be leaked now one thing to note is
that there's no mention of taskmaster at
all with this trailer now recently
there's been a supposedly that says
taskmaster isn't really the main villain
so that could possibly be the reason why
taskmaster was not mentioned in this
trailer and perhaps they're trying to
keep the true nature
of the main villan a secret after all it
is a movie about master assassins and
spies but if this is what we get for the
first teaser trailer let me know are you
happy with this and be sure to comment
down below if you are excited about
Black Widow and the start of phase 4
like the video if you enjoyed it and as
I mentioned be sure to subscribe to my
channel to stay up to date on Marvel
content and so you can enter my giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
I'm picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers I'm also
doing an Infinity Gauntlet giveaway you
can follow me on Twitter to enter and
click the link in the description down
below as well
as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff